bon pour l'instant il se passe trop rien
je vais ouvrir YouTube voir si ça ça
marche quand même désolé de
de faire ces manipulations voilà
sociotech en live ça a l'air de
fonctionner
ah ben voilà ça fonctionne on est aussi
sur Youtube et normalement si tout va
bien dans le chat on aura à la fois
les gens qui sont sur YouTube
et les gens qui sont sur twitch
seulement ça marchera pas que cette vue
si ça sera sur l'autre vue uniquement et
j'ai constaté que sur l'autre vue
c'était pas top niveau de l'overlay mais
là normalement dans la vue que vous avez
il y a le
les maudes ou je sais pas l'icône je
sais pas comment il faut le dire de
twitch ou de YouTube qui apparaîtra bah
voilà ça marche c'est sympa c'est
formidable on est content alors dans la
commande du chat si vous tapez biblio
vous allez avoir l'article qui va vous
être proposé et je pense ce qui est
assez sympa c'est qu'il est en lecture
gratuite donc ça c'est ça c'est cool
et donc ici on va s'intéresser aux
jeunes et à ce que lisent les jeunes et
de voir si comme on le dit les jeunes
lisent de moins en moins qui lit qu'il
ne lit pas qu'est-ce qu'on lit alors on
parle pas de lecture imposée à l'école
c'est vraiment des lectures faites en
dehors du cadre scolaire même si tout a
toujours un lien
et surtout on va regarder si c'est
pratique sont valorisées à l'école et si
c'est un impact sur la scolarité des
élèves donc moi ça m'intéresse beaucoup
parce que je suis convaincu que on est
dans un monde où en fait on lit de plus
en plus alors peut-être pas des ouvrages
légitimes c'est tout l'objet de
l'article mais voilà ça part d'un
questionnement aussi personnel je me
pose beaucoup de questions sur la
lecture et sur les rapports entre ce que
font les élèves en dehors de l'école et
ce qu'on leur demande à l'école je crois
que c'est des questionnements de profs
qui sont pleinement légitimes j'espère
que ça va vous intéresser aussi
comme ça m'a intéressé l'article est
assez sympa vous allez voir parce que
c'est un article notamment
mais bonjour exodiaque tiens comment tu
vas ça fait longtemps ça se passe bien
alors pour répondre à ta question alors
il faut savoir c'est exodiaque ça fait
longtemps que qu'on s'est parlé c'est
exodiaque c'est quand même quelqu'un qui
m'a permis de lancer la chaîne stream
mais ma donner beaucoup de conseils au
départ donc c'est super
super sympa que tu passes faire un petit
coucou alors pour te répondre ils lisent
du fantastique ainsi ici on va pas
tellement s'intéresser au contenu on va
s'intéresser alors si on va s'intéresser
un peu au contenu mais on va pas aller
trop loin dans le contenu et là il y a
une justification méthodologique si tu
commences à demander parce que en fait
ils vont faire une observation
quantitative sur base de questionnaire
mais si tu demandes aux jeunes de
classer de voir leur lecture en fonction
de différents styles littéraires
fantastique je sais pas moi action
suspense enfin tu vois des catégories
comme celle là tu risques d'en perdre
parce que pour certains ça va rien dire
quoi donc ils sont restés sur des
catégories beaucoup plus larges
c'est pas le parti pris d'aller sur le
contenu en tant que tel mais ils vont
rester sur tiens est-ce que tu dis des
magazines des magazines de sport de
divertissement parce que ça c'est des
grandes catégories qui permettent de
bien distinguer ou plutôt sur des romans
et donc là roman fantastique on serait
plutôt dans ce cadre là donc voilà ça
c'est vraiment un parti primate logique
mais que j'apprécie beaucoup parce que
parfois tu te dis mais dans le
questionnaire mais qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
demander tu vois tu comme disait
Bourdieu finalement tu vas poser aux
gens des questions qui sont complètement
déconnectées de leur vie ou des items
qui sont complètement déconnectés de
leur vie donc moi j'ai bien aimé ce
parti pris méthodologique
la question de lecture adolescente était
traitement liée à celle des inégalités
éducatives en raison de la place des
lectures de livres en haut de la
hiérarchie des pratiques culturelles
quoi c'est quand même le truc qui est
super bien vu à l'école la lecture et de
son rôle crucial dans la construction
des inégalités socioculturelles donc ça
on sait depuis très longtemps que le
rapport à l'écrit et aux ouvrages
légitimes à la littérature à une place
importante
et dans l'article Marc questionner ça en
1999 1999 Christian Baudelot Marie
quartier et Christine detrée dresser un
tableau des activités de lecture
l'ivresse que des adolescents et
indiquait un recul général du livre
encore plus marqué au lycée donc ça
c'est un constat on lit de moins en
moins de livres il notait également de
profond de mutation de pratique
lectorales avec un rapport plus pratique
à la lecture qui loin du modèle cultivé
et désormais envisagé dans un but
particulier s'occuper se divertir
apprendre donc tu vas lire beaucoup mais
pas la littérature
ah bah c'est super ça si ça c'est ce
qu'on a fait avec mes collègues ont pu
t'aider et s'appeler sinon
tu es toujours en histoire
c'est bien tu vas pouvoir donner des
feedbacks sur ce que sont les études
supérieures
le gap entre
école secondaire étude supérieure à ça
quand on aura l'occasion de se recroiser
tu ne manqueras pas d'être
prolixe sur ce sujet là moi ça
m'intéresse beaucoup quoi
si chaque génération présente au cours
de son cycle de vie un comportement
similaire à la précédente chaque
génération dénombre à l'origine une part
plus restreinte de gros lecteurs la
lecture souffrant ainsi d'une érosion
structurelle donc ça c'est pas ce qu'on
dit dans l'article c'est vraiment ce
qu'on fait dans ce qu'on dit dans l'état
de l'art c'est la compilation de
différents autres recherches dans
lesquelles on est arrivé à certains
constats qu'on rappelle ici pour pouvoir
construire de manière intelligente
ah c'est sympa ça de ben voilà donc du
coup il y a un stream de sciences
sociales il y a aussi arkan qui est ici
dans le chat qui propose des lectures de
sciences sociales justement le mercredi
matin si ça t'intéresse mais voilà il y
a de l'offre
de niche comme tu m'avais dit mais il y
la compréhension de l'évolution du
rapport à la lecture des adolescents
réponds pour les chercheurs à une
logique plurifactorielle avec notamment
la concurrence d'une offre importante de
loisirs des aspirations adolescentes à
plus d'autonomie qui affaiblit ses
effets des consignes scolaires et des
conseils des parents et la montée en
puissance de la culture d'écran bon
évidemment ça ne pousse pas à lire de
plus en plus et on comprend bien que
c'est un peu corrélé
alors tu m'as appris grâce à tes streams
tu m'as appris c'est de faire un saut
c'est ça mais je sais pas comment on
fait je dois faire
comme ça
ça fait automatiquement ou c'est toi qui
a paramétrer ça
est-ce que tu peux m'apprendre à le
faire je l'ai vu que tu l'avais fait
c'est un saut non comment tu fais quand
tu notes en référence dans le chat une
autre chaîne d'un instrument c'est pas
un saut que tu dis ça
ouais désolé
je
ça paraît sur un site
mais comment tu appelles ça
ouais c'est une commande que tu mets sur
Xbox moi j'utilise Bott
grâce à exodiaque c'est lui qui m'avait
tué
le truc mais comment tu appelles le fait
de taguer quelqu'un je sais pas comment
tu dis dans les stream
un saut un saut un saut
je sais plus je sais plus comment tu le
dis comment tu le prononce
alors ça c'est un peu le contexte et ici
ils vont nous dire directement ce que
veulent faire ah non il rappelle encore
quelques petites choses les travaux
sociologiques sur la lecture viennent
parfois valider une telle approche
l'ouvrage sociologie de la lecture qui
est paru en 2016 n'évoque ainsi le
numérique que pour décrire l'évolution
des supports de lecture avec
l'apparition du livre numérique donc moi
j'aime bien parce qu'il y a une réelle
problématique dans cet article où on te
dit en fait il y a quand même tout un
angle mort dans la recherche actuelle
sur les lectures des jeunes on va
s'intéresser tout le temps au livre
à la littérature en tant que telle et
puis si on s'intéresse au numérique
c'est juste pour le livre numérique mais
on s'intéresse jamais aux autres types
de lecture
je sais pas
je sais pas comment on prononce
un seau tu dirais comme ça un
c'est difficile de
d'apprendre les codes on se rend compte
ce que j'expliquais encore à des élèves
tout à l'heure quand tu expliques que
par exemple il y a des choses qui sont
pas forcément évidentes j'ai des élèves
de 5e qui était fort étonnés d'apprendre
que pour certaines personnes n'étaient
que rarement sortis de leur village
natal alors moi je l'ai vécu j'ai connu
des gens comme ça qui avaient jamais qui
était jamais sorti de leur village natal
on l'a lu ensemble un mardi dans le
Massif central dans le monde du foret où
il y a un village avec des personnes qui
vivent en quasi autarcie alors ils ont
quelques contacts avec l'extérieur
et alors les élèves me disaient les
élèves de 5e donc c'est l'équivalent de
la première en France il me disait oui
mais monsieur mais comment c'est
possible c'est un manque de curiosité et
c'est très difficile de leur faire
comprendre
d'imager ça que acquérir les codes de
quelque chose que tu connais pas donc
par exemple simplement avoir l'envie
d'aller voir l'extérieur quand tu as
toujours vécu en quasiotarcie on entend
milieu que tu connais pas les transports
en commun que t'as pas forcément de
voiture que c'est compliqué
l'acquisition de nouveaux réflexes d'un
nouveau d'une nouvelle culture de
nouveaux contenus comme cela et tu t'en
rends compte finalement avec
twitch puisque moi ça fait même pas un
an que je suis sur twitch c'est super
difficile quoi c'est super et difficile
de maîtriser mais c'est la même chose
quand tu veux refaire des maths quand tu
veux faire de la musique c'est super
difficile d'acquérir des codes
Bertrand Laporte bienvenue sur
alors streambot est-ce que tu es sur
merci en tout cas c'est super gentil
mais j'essaie de voir si c'est sur via
Youtube c'est via YouTube donc c'est que
les liens marchent et ça fait plaisir
mais en tout cas bienvenue sur ce stream
où on essaie d'expliquer ben voilà
quelques articles scientifiques sont
sans avoir forcément une expertise
développée de la recherche en sciences
sociales parce que moi je suis juste
prof de secondaire mais voilà c'est un
peu l'idée que si des personnes veulent
s'initier aux sciences sociales et ce
qu'est un article scientifique mais
finalement ils ont ils ont un stream ou
on leur propose ça
c'est pour ça qu'il faut sortir du mythe
de la compétitivité
comme ça
tu as pas ce biais qui t'empêche de
t'intéresser à quelque chose par peur
d'être mauvais ou de ne pas y arriver
mais en fait oui mais il faudrait une
société de la bienveillance dans
laquelle on ne va pas te juger mais
c'est très difficile dans n'importe quel
milieu tu es souvent considéré comme un
débutant et donc on va te répondre de
manière un peu
un peu sommaire un peu froides en disant
mais c'est quoi encore ce débutant qui
pose des questions de il y a un réel je
pense que c'est un vœu pieux en fait
parce qu'il y a un réel en jeu
symbolique le fait de dominer dans un
champ pour prendre le vocabulaire
bourdieuien est un est un puissant
moteur en fait mais je suis d'accord
avec toi il faudrait une sorte de de
société de la bienveillance dans
laquelle t'as pas peur quoi tu n'as pas
peur de poser des questions bêtes
voilà après je pense que ton origine
sociale quand tu fais partie des classes
moyennes tu as un peu l'habitude aussi
de la bonne volonté culturelle comme
disait Bourdieu et donc du coup t'as pas
peur d'avoir l'herbe bête mais
à poser des questions
[Musique]
mais c'est vrai que c'est un réel enjeu
tout ça
alors on termine l'état de l'art l'état
de l'art c'est le moment où on va
regarder tout ce qui a été fait
précédemment à la recherche en question
et il ne traite de la question de la
diversité des objets de lecture qu'aux
regardent des lectures sur support
papier y compris concernant les lectures
les plus utilitaires pourtant les
réponses aux situations de la vie
quotidienne sont très souvent
recherchées sur Internet et pour tout le
monde qu'on soit jeune ou pas jeune
maintenant c'est internet qui est le
réflexe et donc ça c'était vraiment un
angle mort comme je le disais tout à
l'heure la diffusion massive des
technologies numériques a favoriser un
élargissement considérable des
possibilités de consommation culturelles
et la mutation de ces consommations chez
les adolescents mais si faible fréquence
de lecture de livres et pratiques
numériques intenses sont corrélés la
baisse de la lecture de livres ne peut
être imputée à l'émergence d'Internet
puisqu'elle lui est largement antérieure
donc il y a autre chose aussi Qui est
qui est en jeu
j'aime bien cette manière de poser la
problématique ou tu vois il y a vraiment
quelque chose d'intéressant à aller
chercher il y a un objectif dans cette
recherche cette recherche c'est pas
juste le plaisir de faire une recherche
il y a un réel enjeu de combler un vide
au niveau des connaissances
de façon générale il décrivent pour les
adolescents des lectures sur écran
essentiellement documentaire sollicitant
des compétences spécifiques rapidité
capacités à identifier l'information
pertinente dans un environnement saturé
et de type fragmentaire guidé par les
Libériens donc quand il y a des
recherches c'est ce qu'on nous explique
et on se rend compte que c'est un autre
forme de lecture c'est autre chose
depuis 12 ans de l'expérience alors
en Belgique en France
alors je rappelle que je ne lis pas tout
l'article je lis vraiment des passages
qui me semble plus pertinents donc c'est
un petit peu
il y a un petit peu un comment dire des
liens qui vont manquer et une complexité
de l'article que je ne vais pas aborder
dans ce stream donc ça il faudra aller à
la lecture si vous voulez quelque chose
de plus précis en Belgique aussi
et est-ce que tu fais lire je me permets
qu'on se tutoie
je me permets quand toi je te tutoie
et est-ce que tu abordes avec les élèves
des des articles scientifiques ou est-ce
que ça reste
quelque chose
qui n'est pas possible
ouais il y a beaucoup de profs
francophones de sciences sociales qui
sont sur ce stream
c'est bien je pense que c'est vraiment
important
de les mettre au contact un peu de ces
contenus là
alors que nous dit-on dans la suite de
l'article les travaux sociologiques ont
montré qu'appréhender les pratiques
culturelles des adolescents sous l'angle
de la légitimité culturelle était
insuffisante pour expliquer leurs effets
sur les performances scolaires donc on
pourrait se dire
il y a les contenus légitimes la
littérature
déjà les classiques et puis toute une un
plan de la littérature légitime de
certaines œuvres qui sont valorisées
scolairement mais en 2014 dranan c'est
balle la tort nous disent que c'est
que c'est pas suffisant maintenant dans
cette étude si on va revenir sur ce
constat là quoi et on va voir quand même
l'importance de des cultures des
lectures légitimes ils en déduisent que
ce sont les compétences analytiques et
cognitives développées par la lecture
qui favorise la réussite à l'issulivan
montre quand elle que parmi les
pratiques culturelles des adolescents
seule la lecture et la consommation
télévision les programmes culturellement
ou lexicalement riches sont associés à
une meilleure réussite elle souligne
également que les effets de ces
pratiques sur les performances scolaires
passent par l'acquisition de vocabulaire
et par le développement de ressources
cognitives mais si ces recherches
pointent la centralité de la lecture
dans la compréhension des inégalités
sociales de réussite elles réduisent la
lecture à la lecture papier
essentiellement de livres loin des
pratiques adolescentes actuelles donc
dans toutes les recherches on a vraiment
cette petite musique qui joue et les
lectures numériques
alors le travail présenté dans cet
article analyse les pratiques de lecture
d'adolescents de 12-13 ans donc on a une
population cible assez précise
scolarisée en 5ème et leur lien avec la
réussite scolaire alors que la lecture a
été déclarée Grande cause nationale en
France pour 2021-2022 pour l'éducation
nationale l'enjeu majeur et la lecture
des livres de livres mais que sait-on
des autres lectures adolescentes donc ça
c'est vraiment la question de départ de
cet article nous avons fait le choix de
prendre en compte les principales
pratiques de lecture quelle que soit le
type de texte et le support de son
inscription nous distinguons les
pratiques de lecture par la fréquence le
support papier livre journal revue ou
numérique et le contenu donc ça c'est
vraiment les trois variables qu'on va
qu'on va investiguer cet article
présente les pratiques électorales
adolescentes et analysent les relations
entre réussites scolaire et objets et
support de lecture voir manière de lire
en considérant les différentes les
différences fortes entre lecture
traditionnelles et lecture numérique
vous allez voir c'est assez décapant moi
j'étais étonné des résultats
par rapport à cette lecture numérique il
interroge aussi les déterminants
socio-scolaires des pratiques ainsi que
les incitations à lire afin de mieux
comprendre la construction des choix de
lecture et leur lien avec la culture
scolaire alors on va voir que sur les
incitations la lecture on va rester un
petit peu sur notre fin que là la
recherche va déboucher sur une impasse
en tout cas on va avoir rien de
d'intéressant sur ce point là pour cette
recherche nous avons fait le choix
d'appréhender les lectures par les
supports et les contenus et non par la
légitimité néanmoins les questions
légitimité scolaire ne sont pas absentes
de cette catégorie de lecture retenue
et voilà bon j'ai déjà abordé la
question de la légitimité parce que il y
a certains choix méthodologiques qui ont
été faits dans des études précédentes
qui étaient pas à judicieux pour les
auteurs de celle-ci alors on a toujours
un encart un encadré méthodologique
c'est une enquête par questionnaire qui
a été faite pour l'observation et ici
ils ont interrogé quand même
1685 élèves de 5e dans 16 collèges de
Bretagne situé en zone urbaine
périurbaine et rurale donc là on a une
diversité au niveau du type
d'établissement même s'ils sont
géographiquement
localisés au même endroit dont trois
collèges d'enseignement privé donc il y
a même de l'enseignement privé et quatre
collèges en éducation prioritaires donc
là ils ont bien panaché l'ensemble des
élèves des classes de 5e de chaque
établissement étant enquêté donc là on a
vraiment
une enquête exhaustive par rapport à la
population cible
ça c'est plutôt bien dans chaque classe
la très grande majorité des élèves a
répondu au questionnaire la passation a
été réalisée en classe et ceci c'est un
bon point ça évite de nombreux billets
si je peux me permettre cher professeur
sur ce stream mais allez-y très cher
pète lire des articles scientifiques à
vos élèves cela n'est pas bénéfique pour
ceux qui continueront cela
n'est que bénéfique pour ceux qui
continueront leurs études mais merci
exodiaque
ainsi si un adolescent peut savoir sans
hésitation s'il lit des romans tous les
jours toutes les semaines tous les mois
au plus rarement il devient difficile de
répondre de façon fiable si la question
porte sur un genre de roman ou des
auteurs particuliers et donc c'est ce
qu'on disait où ils sont pas rentrés
dans le détail des contenus pour éviter
un billet
au niveau de la collecte des données
pour notre enquête nous avons fait le
choix de construire des catégories
similaires en les simplifiant et en les
adaptant au public adolescents visés
donc il y a vraiment un souci de
d'éviter tout billet dans la collecte
des données et c'est vrai que j'avais vu
je me souviens plus de l'enquête j'avais
vu une enquête dans laquelle on posait
des questions à des élèves tu dis voilà
déjà un adulte tu as du mal à pouvoir y
répondre
alors certains élèves forcément ils vont
ils vont être perdus par rapport à ce
questionnaire alors je reviens sur le
cœur de l'article la fréquence de
lecture des livres roman aux bandes
dessinées ont été croisées avec une
variable rendant compte d'une lecture
numérique quotidienne décalée pour au
moins une des thématiques proposées que
leur lecture de bande dessinée soit rare
régulière au quotidien environ un tiers
des adolescents déclare une lecture
quotidienne sur Internet les lectures
numériques ne s'opposent donc pas à la
lecture de livres donc ça c'est déjà un
premier constat on n'a pas une
opposition et une concurrence entre les
deux cités un gros lecteur de livres tu
es aussi un gros lecteur de contenu sur
Internet
un gros lecteur un bon lecteur
mais ça personnellement c'est un peu ce
que je pensais quoi
pour la lecture de roman néanmoins
l'enquête montre que les plus forts
lecteurs ont des consommations internet
moindres donc sauf pour la lecture de
roman donc lecture de magazine ça match
bien papier ça marche bien avec des
lectures sur le net par contre lecture
de roman plus tu lis des romans moins tu
vas consommer des contenus sur le net
donc il y a une concurrence entre la
lecture de roman et les lectures sur sur
le net un quart des lecteurs quotidiens
de romans déclare lire quotidiennement
sur internet quand c'est le cas de 43%
des faibles lecteurs de romans donc il y
a vraiment un lien entre les deux le
questionnaire a été pensé pour mettre en
évidence les articulations entre lecture
papier lecture numérique en effet hormis
les romans et les bandes dessinées les
lectures étaient classées par thème avec
une reprise pour les lectures numériques
des contenus interrogés pour les
lectures d'imprimer donc on va voir une
similitude
ce sont les contenus sportifs qui
présentent la plus grande continuité
thématique entre les deux supports 70
70% des adolescents qui déclarent lire
quotidiennement des contenus sportifs
imprimés déclare également lire
numériques suivre les contenus de
divertissement 60% culturel 52% et
animalier 50 %
. donc il y a une cohérence les contenus
historiques scientifiques et d'actualité
connaissent une moindre continuité entre
papier et numérique avec respectivement
45 32 et 20% des adolescents déclarant
lire quotidiennement à la fois des
magazines sur cette thématique et des
informations numériques
l'ensemble des résultats indique une
tendance des plus forts lecteurs
d'informations imprimées a complété
leurs informations en ligne néanmoins là
encore les contenus les plus proches de
la lecture scolaire se démarquent sur
cette thématique alors que le numérique
temps de façon générale à supplanter les
lectures d'imprimer la majorité des
forts lecteurs de magazines sont plus
nombreux à se limiter au lecture papier
ce constat soulève la question
d'éventuelles prescriptions de lecture
traiter dans la suite de cet article
alors je vais vous montrer
un tableau
qui offre une bonne synthèse déjà de des
premiers éléments
[Musique]
constatés les premiers éléments les
premiers éléments c'est difficile les
liaisons
fenêtre de travail ou là
on va faire comme ça
on va faire quelque chose de propre
aujourd'hui agrandir avant
de rogner
voilà ici
un tableau sympa
et donc là on voit le positionnement
des différents
des différentes fréquences de lecture et
donc par exemple ici tu vois ou là c'est
devenu
un peu space sur
je sais pas ce que j'ai fait
j'ai fait une fausse manœuvre sur le PC
j'espère que c'est
que sur mon écran
oui chez vous ça va c'est bon
donc ici tu vois par exemple le lecteur
de BD ils sont 25% à lire
quotidiennement ou presque de la bande
dessinée donc il faut tracer je sais pas
comment on dit le triangle
jusque
à l'axe lui quotidiennement et puis si
tu reportes BD sur l'autre axe donc là
horizontalement tu arrives à 20% qui ne
lisent jamais de BD et pour le dernier
axe là tu reportes le solde tu es un peu
plus de 50% de lecteurs
intermédiaires de bandes dessinées donc
on voit que les bandes dessinées sont
les contenus qui sont les plus
régulièrement lu
comme les romans
puisque lui quotidiennement les infos
donc là on est plutôt sur des contenus
de magazines ou sur le net info culture
animaux Infosport quoi animaux c'est un
petit peu plus en retrait voilà c'est
ensuite et puis après info histoire
mag histoire ces choses-là sont lus très
rarement puisqu'il en même temps ils
sont très hauts et très proches
du zéro dans Luc quotidiennement presque
donc ça c'est déjà une bonne synthèse
merci arcane d'être passé c'est super
sympa
oui merci oui ben j'espère que nous
sommes plusieurs profs de sciences
sociales passionnés
en tout cas oui c'est toujours
passionnant moi je passe toujours de
très bons moments et je ne me vois pas
faire autre chose qu'enseigner des
sciences sociales tellement j'y trouve
une satisfaction personnelle et puis je
pense que si on est passionné par nos
matières on ne peut être que passionnant
alors peut-être qu'on met pas toujours
passionnant mais en tout cas c'est une
bonne condition qui est déjà remplie
d'être passionnant passionné par nos
matières alors sociologie est un sport
de combat on l'avait passé sur la chaîne
Youtube
et donc c'est intéressant aussi alors je
le passe pas forcément parce que bon
si je me trompe pas ça fait deux heures
trente donc c'est déjà un peu long
mais ouais c'est passionnant et c'est un
bon truc à passer pour montrer aux
élèves aussi qui était Pierre Bourdieu
oui sciences humaines ici on a encore lu
un article super intéressant sur les
vacances des milieux populaires
ça c'était intéressant oui cherche Pogam
c'est aussi c'est aussi sympa quoi
alors continuons la lecture
je re Suisse la vue
Zim
alors les filles sont plus fortes
électrices de romans et les garçons
lecteurs de bandes dessinées ça c'est un
premier constat ils ont croisé aussi le
sexe le genre avec
les niveaux de lecture les lectures
autre que les livres sont aussi
différenciés selon le sexe avec des
filles se distinguant par les contenus
culturels et animaliers quel que soit le
support et les garçons déclarants plus
fréquemment des lectures de sport les
sciences et l'histoire tout support
confondu aussi ainsi que des contenus
numériques de divertissement célébrités
bien de consommation jeux ces constats
de pratique de lecture très genrés sont
à mettre en lien avec la socialisation
les socialisations différenciées défis
et des garçons dans la famille à l'école
et dans les groupes de père notamment
alors ça c'est des thèmes intéressants
aussi parce que déjà les élèves toujours
très intéressés par les questions de
genre ou
de socialisation différenciées après
c'est un grand sujet de discussion avec
les élèves de cette année en 6e donc au
niveau terminal
puisque je des élèves qui disent oui
mais bon il y a des des thèmes des
combats des luttes qui sont menées
maintenant par les plus jeunes
générations notamment sur mais les
stéréotypes de genre qui sont donc en
passe de disparaître je leur dis mais
non ça c'est vous peut-être dans votre
milieu où ça se passe comme ça mais
globalement les stéréotypes de genre
sont encore bien présents je suis je
vais pas dire content parce que j'ai pas
être content que ça existe ou pas mais
en tout cas voilà ça ne m'étonne pas que
dans des études comme celle-ci qui sont
celles-ci a été publiée cette année
c'est tout récent c'est tout frais tu as
toujours des constats qui sont qui sont
les mêmes par rapport à ça
donc qui influence l'ensemble des
pratiques culturelles et la lecture en
particulier les filles sont ainsi plus
souvent incités à lire des livres les
garçons plus fréquemment orientés vers
les contenus sportifs on peut aussi y
voir les effets d'une offre éditoriale
très en ré donc là il y a aussi un effet
économique d'offre qui joue à laquelle
les adolescents à un moment crucial de
leur construction des identités de genre
sont très réceptifs
les résultats sont aussi très
différenciés selon le milieu social et
là ça va devenir très intéressant les
élèves les plus favorisés socialement
privilégient les lectures papiers romans
bande dessinée actualité science ce de
milieu populaire les contenus numériques
de divertissement
le nombre de livres donc ça c'est c'est
quand même quelque chose de très
intéressant mais je vais pas en dire
trop maintenant je vais me retenir de
trop parler là dessus maintenant parce
qu'on va encore en dire plus loin et je
réagirai plus loin le nombre de livres
présents domicile familial indicateur du
capital culturel familial est également
très lié aux pratiques lectorales des
adolescents donc plus tu vas avoir une
bibliothèque bien garni chez toi plus tu
auras tendance à lire avec de plus
fortes fréquences de lecture papier
diversifiée pour les analyses les
adolescents disposant des bibliothèques
familiales les plus fournies et des
lectures numériques proches de la
culture scolaire de lecture numérique de
sciences ou d'histoire moins rare que
leurs camarades l'enquête indique aussi
des différences liées au niveau scolaire
encore plus sensible que celle liée au
milieu social conformément en travaux
intérieurs les élèves les plus en
réussites privilégie des lectures
scolairement valorisées romans magazine
scientifique quand les contenus de
divertissement papier caractérise les
lectures des élèves les plus faibles
mais la recherche apporte aussi un
regard renouvelé sur la diversité des
lectures des adolescents en montrant
comment les lectures numériques
contribuent à la différenciation des
pratiques tout en étant moins
sociologiquement sociaux scolairement
pardon marqué que les lectures
d'imprimées en particulier lecture
numérique sur l'actualité les sciences
et l'histoire proche de la culture
scolaire ne sont pas significativement
différenciés selon le positionnement
social ça c'est un truc qui est je vais
pas dire révolutionnaire mais moi qui
m'a vraiment beaucoup surpris
pour la simple et bonne raison que on va
te dire il y a une fracture numérique
alors qui est présente mais on va te
vendre comme enfin pour moi c'est
l'arbre qui cache la forêt dans le sens
où selon moi selon ce que j'ai pu lire
un documenter c'est plutôt un rapport au
savoir qui est problématique et qui est
profondément inégalitaire donc on vient
vraiment sur les travaux de Bourdieu
et de ceux de comme Bernard laïque qui
ont travaillé dans sa foulée même s'ils
sont détachés
que le fait d'avoir un ordinateur ou pas
parce que pendant la crise du covid en
Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles on a
inondé les écoles d'ordinateurs pour
prêter aux populations les plus
précarisées mais en fait tu vas rien
résoudre de la fracture numérique si tu
penses que c'est juste en donnant un PC
que tu vas résoudre le problème c'est
pas ça le problème c'est un rapport et
si j'ai envie de dire tu vois bien que
c'est pas le numérique qui a un problème
parce qu'en fait
la variable numérique est plutôt
égalitaire puisque les lectures sont
très peu différenciées en fonction de
l'origine sociale quand il s'agit de
lecture en ligne et le problème c'est
bien la culture légitime
voilà c'est pas la culture légitime en
tant que telle qui est forcément un
problème mais c'est son imposition comme
comme élément d'apprentissage et
d'enseignement qui est plus
problématique et ça je trouve ça
vraiment intéressant que cette étude là
mettre ça sur sur le devant de la scène
allez c'est super sympa oui oui on peut
on peut échanger sur la société qui
mes coordonnées ou alors via la page où
YouTube ou via facebook enfin je suis
sur tous les réseaux sociaux avec le
compte la société donc il y a pas de
souci en sachant que
comment dire des collaborations lourdes
de préparation de séquences et tout ça
j'ai plutôt refusé parce que j'ai pas le
temps de m'investir dans ça mais si
c'est sur des échanges ou des actions
ponctuelles de collaboration
des études croisées on peut mettre les
élèves les étudiants sur différentes
choses c'est ça c'est possible quoi
voilà ou avec des stagiaires qui
interviennent sur je sais pas on peut
inventer plein de choses différentes moi
je suis assez ouvert mais en sachant que
j'ai pas forcément beaucoup de temps à
consacrer sur des gros projets à long
terme de co-construction de de support
ou d'outils
ça c'est après ça peut être aussi
d'organiser de quoi moi ce que
j'aimerais co-organiser alors sur twitch
mais ça peut être aussi en présentiel
avec les élèves qui organisent ça c'est
d'accueillir
un sociologue des chercheurs de
rencontrer bon voilà si on est plusieurs
à faire une démarche et peut-être créer
un petit pôle de de quelques enseignants
où on va se regrouper dans le Hainaut
par exemple pour faire sur charleroi ou
sur Mons ou quelque chose comme ça une
collaboration où on va faire venir du
public pour faire une conférence par
exemple ça peut être intéressant pour
avoir quelqu'un qui qui vient dans une
conférence moi c'est quelque chose que
j'aimerais mettre en place mais bon le
problème des options sciences sociales
c'est que parfois on est seul dans nos
écoles quoi donc ça c'est un peu mais
ponctuellement moi je suis vraiment très
partant très chaud pour faire des choses
ponctuelles
donc il y a pas de souci
je suis là tous les mardis sur sur
twitch ou sur Youtube et le dimanche
sauf ce dimanche ici où je serai pas en
ligne
mais sinon voilà quoi
il y a pas de souci
alors
donc ça c'est très intéressant après il
passe dans le dur au niveau statistique
et si si tu es élève il faut bien le
dire que si tu veux vraiment faire des
séances sociales il y a quand même une
part de statistiques à maîtriser quoi
souvent on a des élèves qui viennent en
sciences sociales et qui maîtrisent pas
trop les maths il vient dans science
sociale justement pour éviter les
options scientifiques où il y a trop de
maths mais en sciences sociales il y a
quand même un peu de de stats il y a des
notions qu'on utilise alors on va pas
forcément calculer parce que c'est les
logiciels qui calcule pour nous mais il
faut comprendre un petit peu ce qu'on
calcule et pour qu'on le calcule
donc ici font des régressions
logistiques ordinales en fait on va
établir des des proportions des
probabilités je sais pas si le terme est
correct mais ça ressemble à ça en tout
cas oui il est probabilités si le terme
est correct
ah c'est cool oui j'ai déjà pensé faire
des trucs avec l'UCL mais ça ça pourrait
être intéressant de essayer de croiser
ça quoi
moi je pense que qu'un vraiment quelque
chose qui serait salutaire en secondaire
chez nous en Belgique en Fédération
c'est justement de relier les séances
sociales à l'université de montrer
vraiment qu'il y a une recherche qui est
foisonnante en sciences sociales même si
peut-être que c'est de moins en moins
vrai mais voilà quoi c'est vraiment
super important parce que je suis
d'accord avec toi quand tu disais tout à
l'heure que c'est des disciplines qui
sont très peu visibles alors qu'il y a
dans de nombreuses universités des
facultés de sciences sociales quoi c'est
ça qui est dingue
souvent des facultés de science
économiques et sociales mais
c'est très peu c'est très peu connu
c'est vraiment
interpellant quelque part
alors en anthropologie nous on a lu un
article d'Olivier servais
et donc là c'est mais lui je pense qu'il
est sur ce qu'il est sur Namur ou l'ULB
je sais plus
qui Olivier servais si tu connais pas
c'est il a
observer comment fonctionner des guilds
de dans certains jeux vidéo dans World
of Warcraft pour ne pas le citer et
c'est très intéressant et là du coup ça
ça comment dire ça ça intéresse
directement les élèves bonsoir Gilles
bienvenue sur ce stream bienvenue sur
Youtube
donc on lit un article de science
sociale qui est ici consacrée à la
lecture
des élèves alors ce sont des élèves de
Breton de 5e de 5e en France donc ils
ont 12-13 ans et on regarde comment leur
lecture surtout la lecture numérique
s'articule
avec la réussite scolaire et avec les
différentes variables sociologiques
traditionnelles oui c'est ça c'est
vraiment interpellant Bertrand pourquoi
est-ce que alors qu'on a des facultés de
sciences économiques et de sciences
sociales et surtout à une science
sociale qui sont
très importante pourquoi est-ce que les
élèves n'ont pas une vision claire de ce
que sont les sciences sociales et leurs
parents non plus j'ai envie de dire à
part ceux qui qui ont sans doute fait
des études universitaires mais des gens
qui sont restés en dehors du circuit
universitaire ont très peu de vue de
représentation par rapport à ça
ah ben voilà moi ça m'intéresserait
vraiment de l'interviewer sur sur twitch
après on peut imaginer plein de choses
si tu n'as pas trop le temps non plus ça
peut être de co-interviewer Olivier
servais bon je pense que le fait ça peut
être aussi pendant les heures de course
ça peut être aussi des élèves qui
interview en ligne comme ça le
l'anthropologue par contre je me rends
compte que sur l'overlay je n'ai plus le
chat qui apparaît mais c'est pas très
grave
je réglerai ça plus tard
donc ici qu'est-ce qu'on nous dit avec
ces régressions logistiques ordinales
qui sont des probabilités
hormis la lecture d'actualité qu'elle
soit imprimée ou en ligne il est
pratique lectorales sont tout d'abord
très fortement sexuées sans on l'a déjà
dit mais ça se vérifie à l'analyse
statistique être une fille augmente la
probabilité d'être une lectrice de
romans et diminue fortement celle d'être
une forte lectrice de bande dessinée
d'informations sportives et
d'information de divertissement le
milieu familial mesurait par l'indice de
recherche ou de rocher je sais pas je
connais pas cet indice je joue également
mais uniquement pour les lectures
d'imprimer un milieu favorisé accroît
les chances d'être un fort lecteur de
livres de livres et un milieu populaire
diminue celui d'être un fort lecteur
d'actualité avec toutefois des effets
observés nettement plus faibles que ceux
liés aux genres donc en fait tu as
plutôt des inégalités de genre que des
inégalités de socio socio-économiques ou
socioculturel
les phénomènes de transmission familiale
sont ici moins importants que dans des
études antérieures analysant les
pratiques électorales mais
souvenons-nous que les lectures
antérieures elles s'intéressaient
principalement au support papier et
qu'ici la particularité de cette étude
c'est aussi de s'intéresser aux supports
numériques et que on vient de dire que
les supports numériques étaient moins
clivants socialement que les supports
papiers c'est logique
à l'ULB la faculté de philosophie et
sciences sociales est un peu une faculté
Fourtou il y a plein d'autres
départements de sciences humaines
alors à Louvain la Faculté de
Philosophie et Lettres est séparée de la
faculté de sciences
sociales qui est regroupé avec
qui est célesto quoi si on se politique
et sociale
et économique
par ailleurs pour les lectures
numériques le milieu social ne fait pas
de différence toutes choses étant égale
par ailleurs les loisirs culturels des
6-14 ans donc ça c'est dans une enquête
précédente
nous rappelle que les élèves ont
réussites ont une probabilité nettement
plus élevée d'être de forts lecteurs les
élèves de faibles niveaux une
probabilité plus basse c'est ce qu'on va
questionner ici dans cette enquête pour
les bandes dessinées c'est là le
scolaire qui a un effet être en retard
augmente très fortement la probabilité
de ne jamais en lire et diminuer
également très sensiblement la
probabilité d'en lire tous les jours
alors là on est face à des corrélations
mais qu'on n'a pas expliqué donc tant
qu'on n'a pas d'explication ça reste
juste des observations statistiques sans
grande conclusion
les élèves les plus en réussites ont
ainsi des lectures numériques plus
légitimes scolairement que les lectures
les élèves en difficulté enfin
tonalité sociale du collège la tonalité
sociale du collège mesurait par l'indice
moyen de positionnement social des
élèves qui sont scolarisés est également
pris en compte l'effet est très fort
concernant les lectures de romance un
contexte favorisé augmente de 18 points
la probabilité d'en lire tous les jours
et diminuant d'autant le fait de ne
jamais en lire donc on a quand même un
effet de de milieu comme ça
d'imprégnation qui va avoir une forte
incidence
rien n'est plus fort que finalement la
socialisation par les Pères c'est ça
qu'on nous dit ici
pour la lecture d'actualité que ce soit
sous forme imprimée ou numérique la
probabilité d'en lire tous les jours je
l'ai dit pardon deux explications
peuvent être avancées un effet
d'entraînement des paires avec une
sur-représentation des forts lecteurs
qui constitueraient une incitation à
lire pour les autres ou des pratiques
enseignantes plus incitatives à la
lecture de contenu les plus légitimes
scolairement dans les contextes les plus
favorisés donc les deux peuvent jouer et
ça c'est ce que j'aime aussi dans des
articles qui ouvrent des perspectives et
là on voit vraiment que on est face à un
processus collectif ou une porte est
ouverte et
un autre chercheur une autre chercheuse
peut se saisir de ce questionnement pour
initier une nouvelle recherche
donc ça c'est aussi des choses qui sont
intéressantes à montrer si on est élève
je pense les résultats suggèrent aussi
un potentiel délecture numérique en
termes de réduction des inégalités
sociales de réussite par exemple alors
que les écarts sociaux observés quant à
la pratique d'information d'actualité
par la presse-papier sont importants
aussi bien pour les analyses bivariées
que pour les analyses toutes choses
étant égales par ailleurs les
différences selon le milieu social ne
sont pas significatifs pour
l'information d'actualité en ligne donc
ça c'est super important dans
l'échantillon qui est celui-ci on ne
constate rien qui impacte au niveau de
la lecture de l'actualité en ligne
une quelconque un quelconque facteur
social
donc je pense que c'est super important
pour comprendre un petit peu comment se
reproduisent les inégalités à l'air du
numérique
alors Fanny renard en 2011 on est
toujours dans
une revue de ce qui a été fait
précédemment
a mis en évidence les influences
croisées sur les lectures des collégiens
des enseignants de la famille et des
pères donc ici on va s'intéresser à qui
incite à la lecture
de façon générale elle montre que les
transmissions verticales restent
centrales pour la lecture pour cet
article nous avons aussi cherché quels
acteurs participent à la construction
des pratiques lectorales en analysant
non seulement la lecture d'imprimée mais
également la lecture numérique je l'ai
déjà dit c'est vraiment la spécificité
de cet article il s'agit de façon
générale d'interroger le rôle des
intermédiaires dans le les choix de
lecture des adolescents de 5e selon les
catégories d'adolescents et selon les
contextes scolaires il s'agit en
particulier d'étudier comment le rôle
des enseignants est articulé à celui des
autres intermédiaires de lecture de
façon générale 25% des répondants
déclarent ne jamais être conseillé sur
leur lecture
54% des adolescents déclarent ainsi être
conseillés dans leur lecture de livres
roman bande dessinée avant tout par les
parents et les autres adultes de la
famille pour 34%, les principaux
intermédiaires de lecture de livres
Après les parents sont les père 21% puis
il les frères sœurs et autres jeunes de
la famille 15%. ces transmission
horizontale sont plus importantes pour
les adolescents de mes lieux favorisés
et forces scolairement
les influences amicales sont aussi plus
présentes pour les filles et dans les
collèges les plus favorisés enfin les
livres sont rarement conseillés par les
professionnels du livre et les
enseignants il apparaît les
professionnels du livre ont un rôle de
conseils beaucoup plus affirmé auprès
des grands lecteurs au contraire des
enseignants en fait on se rend compte
que les enseignants sont très peu ont
très peu d'influences sur les choix de
lecture
hors cadre scolaire des enfants
mais le rôle des enseignants est plus
marqué pour les élèves les plus fragiles
socialement et scolairement donc là ça
augmente un petit peu mais c'est pas non
plus énorme on est en dessous des 20%
. enfin la tonalité sociale du collège
c'était fait d'environnement et corrélé
au déclarations de conseils de livres
avec deux résultats marquants la
sur-représentation des enseignants comme
intermédiaires dans les collèges
populaires et celles des pères dans les
collèges favorisés c'est ce qu'on avait
dit précédemment
concernant les lectures les autres
lectures étudiées journaux et magazines
imprimés et en ligne documents long sur
Internet moins du quart des adolescents
déclare effectuer ses choix en fonction
de conseils reçus mais il y aura un mais
pour les journaux et magazines imprimés
ainsi que pour les documents longs sur
internet ce résultat tient notamment à
la forte proportion de l'adolescence qui
indique ne jamais lire ces contenus
pardon
pour leur camarades les conseils
viennent surtout des parents quand ceux
des pairs et de la fratrie sont rares
les professionnels ont également une
influence très modeste 1 à 2% hormis
pour les textes longs sur internet que
7% des adolescents déclarent lire sur
conseil de leurs enseignants donc
peut-être des articles scientifiques
exodiaque
enfin concernant la navigation ordinaire
sur Internet la plupart des adolescents
déclarent jamais choisir les pages
qu'ils consultent qui consultent en
fonction de conseils reçus ce constat
est néanmoins relativisé car les
adolescents peuvent être des
destinataires de conseils sans les
reconnaître en tant que tel quand tu as
des articles qui ont été très likés sur
les réseaux sociaux sur qui sont
proposés via des liens hypertextes qui
ont été promus par des amis ou encore
des algorithmes qui vont mettre en avant
finalement le résultat de choix d'autrui
tu vois qu'il y a quand même une
influence des pères mais où la figure du
prescripteur est un petit peu
invisibilisée
alors tous ces constats amènent à
repenser les questions des liens entre
lecture adolescentes et culture et
capitaux scolaire à s'interroger sur la
valorisation par l'école des pratiques
électorales hors cadres scolaires ça
c'est aussi assez
détonnant alors il va y avoir une
typologie qui va être réalisée avec
quatre profils de lecteur pour pouvoir
ensuite faire une analyse
avec plusieurs variables
et donc établir des corrélations
on a d'abord le lecteur traditionnel
c'est celui qui va lire du roman qui va
lire des livres papier ça c'est
ce type de lecteur on a le lecteur
spécialiste celui qui va lire une presse
spécialisée qu'elle soit écrite ou
qu'elle soit en ligne avec des thèmes
très précis on peut penser aux revues
sportives ou aux articles sportifs alors
ça c'est assez intéressant je vais lire
tout le petit paragraphe qui consacra ça
mais j'y reviendrai et puis on a les
faibles lecteurs son élève qui lisent
très peu quel que soit les contenus et
les supports mais on a une troisième
catégorie ici qui sont les lecteurs
omnivores et je vais revenir parce que
c'est quelque chose qui est très présent
dès qu'on parle de pratiques culturelles
c'est l'omnivorité
qui s'opposent à l'université
ils sont des concepts qui ont été
formulés dans les années 2000 par
Richard Peterson et c'est un peu souvent
un modèle qu'on va proposer à la suite
de Bourdieu en disant voilà Bourdieu
c'est un peu dépassé parce que
maintenant on est plutôt sur un modèle
d'Omnivore je vais lire le paragraphe et
vous avez comprendre si vous ne savez
pas c'est quoi de quoi il s'agit le
troisième type omnivore exprime les
lectures les plus éclectiques donc le
plus diversifiées les adolescents
proches de ce type lisent des contenus
divers thématiquement et sur tout type
de support donc des gros lecteurs mais
qui vont pas se contenter comme les
traditionnels de lecture de d'ouvrage du
livre
ce sont de grands lecteurs
comparativement à l'ensemble de la
population enquêtée le choix du terme
omnivore fait écho au travail de Richard
Peterson concernant les pratiques
culturelles des différentes classes
sociales aux États-Unis et notamment au
sujet de l'éclectisme des goûts
culturels des classes sociales
supérieures à l'époque de Bourdieu dans
la distinction Bourdieu nous dit les
classes dominantes vont lire les
vont consommer les supports culturels
les contenus culturels les plus
légitimes littérature classique opéra
musique classique et ainsi de suite
Peterson part d'un autre constat alors
je sais pas si exactement il part de
Bourdieu mais en tout cas lui il dit non
les classes dominantes vont parfois
sans canailler vont aller consommer des
contenus très populaires par exemple la
bande dessinée ou de la musique
urbaine
s'intéresser par exemple à la mécanique
ou aller manger de la street food et à
côté de ça garde des consommations plus
légitimes alors que les classes
populaires elles vont se contenter de
rester dans leur couloir et d'avoir des
consommations de classe populaire
finalement donc on a les omnivores des
classes dominantes qui s'opposent au
univores des classes populaires ça c'est
le modèle de Peterson mais très
intéressant et là je vous diffusez le
les graphiques qui sont proposés
qui sont vraiment
très très sympas parce que on apprend
des choses
voilà donc la figure 2 l'appartenance au
profil de lecture selon l'indice de
positionnement social et là on a bien le
classement selon cette typologie on voit
que en fait la théorie de Peterson elle
est pas vérifiée ici et ça c'est sympa
parce que on peut vérifier
la pertinence de cette théorie par
rapport à les échantillons qui a étudié
je relativise bien par rapport à
l'échantillon qui est étudié alors si
vous ne connaissez pas la science
sociale ça c'est un peu ce qui
différencie les sciences dites
naturelles des sciences sociales c'est
que dans les sciences sociales tu es
toujours obligé de relativiser parce que
c'est toujours par rapport au contexte
de l'observation à ton échantillon que
tu as observé tu peux rarement
généraliser de manière certaine
c'est plutôt une erreur de généraliser
on peut multiplier les occurrences on
peut multiplier les observations dans
différents contextes à différents
moments pour voir si des modèles sont
toujours pertinents ou pas s'il y a un
changement mais tu vas arriver rarement
sur des lois générales en disant voilà
j'ai observé ça et ça va être valable
pour l'ensemble de l'humanité jusqu'à la
fin jusqu'à la nuit des temps quoi ça ça
va pas être trop possible en sciences
sociales en tout cas voilà c'est un
petit peu ma façon de voir ça mais je
peux avoir une vision
étriquée ou au partiel de tout ça donc
les
omnivores en fait ils vont se recruter
oui dans
les classes qui ont un indice de
positionnement social plus élevé qui est
ici sont 23% mais tu vois que
c'est une sur-représentation qui est
assez faible on est à 5%
pourquoi est-ce que je me permets de
dire ça mais parce que chez les lecteurs
traditionnels
donc là des lecteurs qui vont aller sur
des contenus très légitimes des livres
papier quelque soit le contenu ça reste
plus légitime qu'une lecture en ligne
lecture d'un blog ou que sais-je d'un
site en ligne et bien là tu vois que on
est à 36% chez ceux qui ont un indice de
positionnement social élevé et on est
que 17% dans l'indice de positionnement
social faible donc là il y a un delta
qui est beaucoup plus important donc il
y a je veux dire ça entre Bourdieu et
Peterson dans cette enquête si c'est
plutôt Bourdieu qui gagne parce que on a
le contenu bon même si c'est un peu
approximatif de dire ça étant donné que
on sait pas ce qu'ils ont lu exactement
c'est peut-être de la fantasy qui est
pas un contenu
légitime au sens de Bourdieu quoi mais
voilà c'est assez intéressant on voit
que comme on peut s'y attendre les
faibles lecteurs sont de plus en plus
dans l'indice de positionnement social
faible et les lecteurs spécialistes
aussi donc c'est intéressant parce que
tu te rends compte que dire que parce
que tu viens la classe moins favorisée
tu auras pas de lecture c'est faux en
fait c'est une lecture très spécialisée
on a affaire à des spécialistes alors on
va voir après quels sont les objets qui
les intéressent
et donc c'est ce qu'on dit ici j'ai
surligné les quatre types de
son socialement très marqués quoi la
typologie et très marquée socialement
les filles sont ainsi davantage incité à
se conforme de oui pardon ça n'a pas
encore vu selon le sexe et bien voilà et
donc on voit que les spécialistes sont
plutôt présents chez les garçons et
l'électrices
les lecteurs traditionnels sont plutôt
délectrices avec une grosse différence
donc là il y a une représentation aussi
en tout cas une influence de la variable
du genre qui joue
et ça s'explique par la socialisation ou
dans la socialisation les filles sont
plus contraintes à
se conformer aux exigences scolaires et
que les exigences scolaires portent
plutôt sur des lectures traditionnelles
mais voilà elles vont aller plutôt sur
des lectures traditionnelles tandis que
dans la socialisation primaire les
garçons sont plus socialisés assez
intéressés au sport à s'intéresser aux
jeux vidéo par exemple et bien ils vont
avoir des consommations plus thématiques
et être dans les lecteurs spécialistes
qui vont s'intéresser à certains sujets
comme je sais pas l'informatique
les chaînes YouTube les enfin voilà ce
qui pourrait intéresser des jeunes des
jeunes gens aujourd'hui mais pas que
alors la fréquence des lectures de
romans et de bandes dessinées par profil
là on voit que toute façon on est sur
des indices très faibles
donc ça je passe la fréquence de lecture
de journaux et de magazine par contenu
et par profil alors là c'est intéressant
et ce qui est intéressant c'est que on
voit que les lecteurs omnivores
sont
omnivores un peu dans tout
ils aiment bien lire de tout
voilà les spécialistes évidemment on se
retrouve principalement dans le sport et
dans les divertissements et les
omnivores sont vraiment des lecteurs
boulimiques j'ai envie de dire qui vont
consommer ce qui se trouve
l'appartenance au profil de lecture
selon les résultats scolaires
les lecteurs spécialistes sont plutôt
ceux qui ont de mauvais résultats
scolaires et on va voir dans les
conclusions que les contenus qui lisent
ils ont quand même une pratique de
lecture mais en fait c'est une pratique
qui est totalement
occultée dans le monde scolaire à
laquelle on s'intéresse pas du tout et
d'ailleurs les enfants eux-mêmes ne font
pas le rapprochement entre lire ce
qu'ils lisent et
la lecture telle qu'elle est pratiquée à
l'école et donc là c'est ce que nous
disait les auteurs dans la conclusion on
verra tout à l'heure il y a peut-être
des ponts à établir les lecteurs
traditionnels sont ceux qui sont les
plus forts à l'école ce qui est logique
puisqu'il y a une adéquation entre les
contenus légitimes le livre qui est
fortement valorisé à l'école par rapport
à des lectures en ligne
et le réussite scolaire donc ça c'est
assez logique mais voilà on voit encore
une forte prégnance de ce qui est le
plus légitime à l'école même si encore
une fois ici on ne sait pas ce qu'ils
lisent exactement
pour ici c'est juste de l'analyse des
résultats ça je peux passer puisqu'on
l'a fait en direct ensemble
voilà
alors dans les conclusions pourtant la
place centrale du livre dans les
pratiques électorales adolescentes et
confirmés par cette recherche qui
contredit les Cassandre de la lecture
donc c'est pas vrai que on lit plus il y
a toujours une pratique de lecture qui
est faite non seulement on observe pas
une concurrence généralisée entre
lecture d'imprimer lecture sur écran
mais des continuités thématiques entre
support papier support numérique
caractérise les pratiques de nombre
d'adolescents mais voilà on est sur un
modèle assez classique assez
conventionnel ou on est sur une
médiation qui n'efface pas la médiation
précédente
je m'explique l'oralité n'a pas été
effacé par l'écrit n'a pas été effacé
par l'imprimerie l'imprimerie n'a pas
été effacée par la presse la presse n'a
pas été effacée par la Radio la radio
n'a pas été effacée par la télé la télé
n'a pas été infassé par le internet 1.0
le Web 1.0 le celui qui est purement
transmissif
le Web 1.0 n'a pas été effacé par le web
2.0 et le web 2.0 n'a pas été effacé par
les réseaux sociaux par twitch et donc
on a en fait vraiment une société qui se
complexifie au niveau de la médiation
des contenus culturels donc c'est de
plus en plus compliqué finalement d'être
d'être un consommateur culturel dans les
sociétés puisque les supports et
d'ailleurs on est nous-mêmes débordés
même si on est des boulimiques de
réseaux sociaux enfin de twitch ou de
YouTube de lecture sur le net de lecture
papier
on est débordé par la quantité de choses
qu'il y a à voir à lire entendre à
écouter de podcast et j'en suis et j'en
passe
évidemment
voilà donc ça c'est assez intéressant
déjà néanmoins la lecture de livres
reste comme pour les recherches
intérieur très liées à la réussite
scolaire très légitimée la rentabilité
scolaire de ces pratiques n'est pas
montrée là je sais plus pourquoi j'ai
souligné ça c'est un peu des
contextualisé j'ai peut-être tout relire
ainsi si la nouvelle norme scolaire et
qu'il faut lire à la fois pour
s'informer se former pour s'instruire se
distraire à la fois beaucoup et bien à
la fois vite et lentement il ne semble
pas pour autant que les réponses des
adolescents à ses injonctions soient
véritablement reconnues en termes de
gratification scolaire parce qu'on se
rend compte que les contenus et les
lectures notamment des des élèves qui
réussissent moins bien à l'école c'est
lecture fameux lecteur spécialiste ne
sont pas gratifiés scolairement parlant
les résultats sujets suggèrent un enjeu
démocratique pour l'école à s'emparer de
la question des lectures adolescente en
les en les envisageant comme ressources
pour les apprentissages quand
aujourd'hui celle qui s'éloigne des
standards scolaires participent surtout
des connaissances
ignorées en l'absence de rôle majeurs de
l'école les conditions sont réunies pour
un renforcement des inégalités sociales
de réussite par les lectures
non-solaires puisque ceux qui
réussissent déjà bien à l'école
continuent à lire des choses qui sont
valorisées à l'école et ceux qui
réussissent pas à l'école lisent mais
des choses qui sont pas valorisées à
l'école c'est sans doute plus vrai que
les parents des milieux populaires vont
se sentir illégitime pour conseiller
leurs enfants en matière de lecture et
laisser faire ou ne pas faire l'école et
donc le problème si les lectures hors
champs scolaires ne sont pas un peu je
vais pas dire encadré parce qu'il s'agit
pas d'encadrer ce que font les élèves
dans leur vie privée mais baliser le
terme balise me semble très juste voilà
tu as des pratiques qui vont peut-être
être
préjudiciables pour les enfants
à l'avenir donc pour leur développement
ça peut être préjudiciable et donc c'est
réellement un enjeu démocratique et je
pense notamment mais il y a on avait lu
un article mais je sais plus du tout
lequel parce que maintenant on commence
à avoir quand même un petit stock
d'articles qui ont été élu on nous
disait que
certains élèves de milieu plus
populaires ou qui sont moins bien
intégrés dans le monde scolaire c'était
perdu à suivre des conseils totalement
fallacieux sur le net d'affaires de
business de faire de faire des
formations de choses en ligne parce
qu'ils avaient pas eu le discernement
par rapport à ça donc il y a vraiment un
enjeu pour l'émancipation
des jeunes me semble-t-il les
adolescents peuvent aussi être incités à
garder pour eux des pratiques qu'ils
savent juger légitimes lire des blogs
sportifs voilà c'est pas un truc que tu
vas partager à l'école alors qu'il y
aura peut-être des choses à faire des
ponts à établir avec ce blog je pense
dans des
de sciences sociales où on peut étudier
le foot comme un objet d'étude
ou d'autres sports d'ailleurs je fais
une séquence en cinquième sur sur le
sport et la réussite dans le sport
ça on peut en reparler une fois dans un
prochain stream
mais en français voilà pourquoi pas
quand il y a des rédactions à faire le
faire sous forme d'un bloc sportif
d'envoyer des élèves faire des comptes
rendus de rencontres sportives enfin
voilà à mon sens il faut se rapprocher
aussi
du vécu des élèves sont édulcorer les
contenus
mais je pense que voilà c'est comme ça
qu'on peut raccrocher certains élèves
qui sont moins bien avec la chose
scolaire dans celle-ci pourtant sans
médiation saignante les lectures de
l'essentes peinent à participer à la
construction de connaissances et de
disposition favorable alors réussite
scolaire notamment pour les plus
fragiles socialement et scolairement et
donc je me répète par rapport à ce que
je disais tout à l'heure tu vas mettre
dans les écoles des du matériel
informatique en pensant que simplement
leur donner du matériel informatique va
résoudre la question des inégalités
sociales ça se fait il y a des SBL qui
fait ça ouvertement ou c'est un peu son
slogan mettons des des outils numériques
en classe et on va résorber les
inégalités scolaires mais en fait c'est
les pratiques
et l'encadrement de ces pratiques qu'il
faut qu'il faut changer et pas des
pratiques scolaires des pratiques hors
scolaires donc comment l'école peut-elle
avoir une influence sur ce qui se passe
en dehors de l'école là et la grande
question voilà et bien je vous remercie
en tout cas pour votre attention je vois
que le chat est au calme et donc je vous
remercie pour la participation et
l'accueil pour tous les
viewers sur Youtube ça fait plaisir de
voir qu'on peut toucher aussi d'autres
personnes sur Youtube merci donc à
exodiaque pour le petit coucou c'était
super sympa tu passes quand tu veux
merci à Bertrand à Gilles qui sont
passés sur Youtube merci à bien sûr
Arken grand animateur de ce chat merci à
Phoenix si je me trompe pas qui est
passé en début de stream faire un petit
coucou ça fait toujours plaisir merci
aussi à astro
qui est également passé en début de
stream ça fait toujours plaisir et je
vous remercie on se donne rendez-vous
mardi prochain pour un prochain stream
de sciences sociales je sais pas encore
sur quoi vous pouvez éventuellement nous
suivre je dis nous parce que on est
plusieurs intervenir dans le discord je
vous mets le lien ici
et pour la bibliographie parce que c'est
sur discord que je donne le plus de de
suite sur ce qui va se passer dans les
streams et pour la bibliot du jour que
ça soit les articles qui ont été lu dans
le warm up ou l'article qui vient d'être
terminé à l'instant mais voilà vous avez
toutes les infos qui sont ici je vous
souhaite une bonne soirée une bonne nuit
et à très bientôt et amusez bien avec
les sciences sociales ciao ciao
et il faut que je retrouve juste
Obs voilà